right but you also come from Europe no
they have believed left Europe first
they have different approach to our
privacy I'm not happy the world art and
I'm just talking about turbulence
privacy but does that concern you today
again I'm personally previous a fair
okay I don't worry too much but my own
privacy and I'm a very public person I
do all on my working public I have very
little that I'd like to care about it
and it's it's not something I I think
it's inevitable there's going to be a
lot of data people are going to know a
lot about you people who worry about
your DNA being available in various
databases are correct it's going to be
available in a lot of databases and even
if you are careful the fact that you
have family members who went means that
there's a lot of data about you and I
think that's the fact and I I don't
think it's necessarily even a problem
but I think it can be problematic in
certain circumstances but I think making
the privacy rules Victor is something
that eventually even the US will will
wake up to right so there will be that
kind of protection but let's face it
fate is cheap it's and it's not going
away
anybody who thinks it's not
bang-bang-bang way is just deluding
themselves
you